بفضل اداء البرتغال المتكامل خلال البطوله
تابع رونالدو طريقه للفوز بجائزه الحذاء
الفضي محرزا ثلاثه اهداف وساهم في ثلاثه
في البطوله لحظه تاريخيه له اذا اضاف كاسا
اخرى الى مجموعته كما ساعد بلده ليصبح
افضل فريق في اوروبا قاطبه
لست راضيا ولكنني دائما اعرف انني الوحيد
الذي اريد المزيد حصلت على اربع جوائز
واريد الجائزه الخامسه انوي الحصول على
مجموعه الحذاء الذهبي كامله وهذه الجوائز
اضافيه لريال مدريد كاكبر نادي في العالم
ويجب ان يربح الالقاب في كل عام تابع
رونالدو التقديم عروض مذهله مع ريال مدريد
ومهاراته تتطور في شكل متواصل وقد تطور
ليصبح لاعبا اساسيا في الفريق بفضل مواسم
رائعه واصل رونالدو الفوز باربع جوائز كره
ذهبيه اخرى ليصل الى رقم قياسيا بخمس
جوائز وهو رقم حققه مره واحده فقط قبله
خصمه اللدود ومنافسه في الدوري الاسباني
ليونيل ميسي الفائز هو كريستيانو رونالدو
[تصفيق]
حين ذكروا الاسم في البدايه بدا قلبي يخفق
بسرعه وازداد توتري انها لحظه صعبه بصراحه
لكن اعتقد انني استحقها نوير يستحقها ايضا
وكذلك ميسي لكنني كنت الاحق بها السنه
الماضيه لذا انا مسرور جدا بذلك
انه احد افضل اللاعبين على مر الزمان ولا
احد يستطيع قول غير ذلك انه من افضل
اللاعبين على مر العصور بكل بساطه
يقولون انه افضل لاعب في العالم ويتناقشون
في شان بيليه ودييو مارادونا ولابد من
وجودهما في المعادله لانهما كان لاعبين
مذهلين لكن اعتقد ان الجدير بالقول ان
بيليه لم ينافسه لاعبون معاصرون وكذلك
في ظل غياب منافسين يتحدونهما اما رونالدو
فينافسه ميسي وميسي ينافسه رونالدو وقد
ساعد ذلك كليهما
وكان سجالا سنويا لاعوام متلاحقه عندما
يحين موعد جائزه الكره الذهبيه رونالدو ام
ميسي وكل محبا لكره القدم في العالم له
راي في ذلك وقد يتغير ذلك الراي لان
الاداء والنجاح متبادلان بينهما لكن
الحقيقه ان كل منهما احرز خمس جوائز كره
ذهبيه لم يفترق مطلقا حين يتقدم احدهما
يتمكن الاخر من مطاردته وتقليص الفارق
ويبدو مناسبا حصول كل منهما على خمس منها
على الرغم من ان رونالدو معروف بلعبه
لفريق ريال مدريد انتشرت شائعات من جديد
بانه يتطلع الى الانتقال الى نادي اخر لا
احد يدري
الله وحده يعلم لا اعلم ما يخبئه المستقبل
لكنني سعيد جدا مع ريال مدريد لا احد يدري
مع انتهاء عقده عام 2018 كانت مساله وقت
فحسب قبل ان يعرف الجمهور مكان مخبا
للفائز بجائزه الكره الذهبيه خمس مرات انا
اشعر بالراحه في نادي ريال مدريد
واريد البقاء فيه واما عن النادي الايطالي
فلا ادري ايهما افضل اكثر لالعب فيه
ولكنني احترمهم كثيرا لديهم لاعبون
مخضرمون ودفاع الايطالي يقويون ويصعب
اختراقه ولكن ربما في المستقبل لا احد
يعرف لا اعرف لكن قبل انتهاء مده عقده
واجه ريال مدريد فريق يوفنتوس في ربع
نهائي دوري الابطال خلال تلك المباراه سجل
رونالدو احد ابرز الاهداف التي راها احد
على الاطلاق
يستمر تقديم عرضا حقيقيا لافضل اهداف
رونالدو مرارا وتكرارا لكن هناك هدف يبرز
ربما فوق بقيه الاهداف وذلك في تورينو ضد
يوفنتوس في ربع نهائي دوري الابطال لعام
2018 ويصفه
الايطالي الرائع بانه من اهداف لعبه بلاي
ستيشن
ركله مقصيه مزدوجه انفجاريه تمثل خلاصه
المهاره الرياضيه بتوقع مذهل وبدهاء وجراه
مطلقه
ثم رونالدو
يا له من هدف كريستيانو رونالدو مذهل
اروع رياضي في تاريخ دوري الابطال
بجمال مطلق قليل من اللاعبين يمكنهم تخيل
ذلك الهدف واقل منهم قد يحاولون تسجيله
وربما واحد فقط سيسجله وقد سجله رونالدو
ركله مقصيه خلفيه لا تصدق ووقف مشجع
يوفنتوس للتصفيق له انه مزيج مذهل من
الرؤيه والتقنيه والمهاره الرياضيه
والجراه المطلقه
لم ارى قط جمهورا يصفق واقفا لافضل لاعب
لدى الخصم يحرز هدفا كهذا
وحتى رونالدو نفسه يقول انه افضل هدف سجله
في حياته حتى الان بعد تلك المباراه بدا
يوفنتوس محادثات مع ريال مدريد ورونالدو
في شان عقده وبعد ذلك الاستقبال الحميمي
له في يوفنتوس خلال مباراه دوري الابطال
صرح رونالدو بان رونالدو رائع بقاعده
مشجعين محبين للغايه لكن مع اقتراب انتهاء
مده عقد رونالدو السيكون يوفنتوس محطته
الجديده مايو من عام 2018 محطه بارزه في
مسيره رونالدو لعب ريال مدريد ضد ليفربول
في نهائي دوري الابطال في كييف وهزموهم
بثلاثه اهداف لهدف احرز رونالدو 15 هدفا
في دوري الابطال لذلك الموسم للموسم
السادس على التوالي هو الهداف الاول في
المنافسه مع احراز كاس دوري ابطال اخرى
لريال مدريد وهي خامس بطوله دوري ابطال
لرونالدو وهذا رقم قياسي ثم بعد المباراه
يشير الى المده التي قضاها في النادي
مستخدما الزمن الماضي وكان صدمه لريال
مدريد لان رونالدو كان يف كر في الانتقاد
واتذكر انني كنت في روسيا كانت مرحله نصف
النهائي والنهائي في نهايات كاس العالم
لعام 2018 وكانت وسائل الاعلام الكرويه
العالميه كلها هناك وقد ابهر رونالدو
ابصار الجميع لان الاخبار المفاجئه لم تعد
حول روسيا ولا كاس العالم بل عن تورينو
لان رونالدو انضم الى صفوف يوفنتوس